-Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Thank you so much.
-Thank you.
-This is your U.S. TV debut.
-Yes.
-It is.
-It is tonight.
I have to say, we tweeted out
that you guys were coming on.
And I want to say,
in maybe 5 seconds,
it was 20,000 likes, and we were
all trending at the same time.
So, you have
a lot of fans out there.
-Yeah.
-It's fun, it's fun.
"Young Royals" is one of
the biggest shows in Sweden,
and now it's getting popular
all over the world.
Here you are on the cover
of "Vogue Scandinavia."
-Whoo!
-Look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Omar, did you expect this show
to take off like this?
-I mean, we kind of
saw that coming, I would say.
[ Laughter ]
But --
-Oh, please.
-But -- But -- But --
Let me finish.
Because I really
love the storyline.
And I fell in love with
the script when I first read it.
And now --
The only thing, though --
I could never imagine
that we would be on
"The Fallon Show" in New York.
So now it's kind of, like,
getting to me.
-Oh, yeah, all right.
Okay, that's good.
-So, I'm like,
"Oh, it's pretty --
it's pretty big now, yeah."
-Slowly realizing.
-Yeah.
-Slowly.
-Edvin, can you tell everyone
what the show is about,
for people who haven't seen it?
-Yeah, Well, in short,
it's a story about freedom
and being who you are.
But we follow
the prince of Sweden.
And he's a bit
of a party prince, I guess.
-Yeah.
-Whoo!
[ Laughter ]
Not that kind of party Prince.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-He gets sent to this
boarding school in Sweden,
named Hillerska.
And he meets Simon,
and he falls in love.
That creates
all kinds of issues.
-Yeah, exactly, yeah.
It is so well done, by the way.
I will also give props
to Netflix
because they do a dubbing,
audio dubbing,
in English perfectly,
by the way.
-But you know that's us.
-No.
Doing the -- yeah.
-That's you doing the voice?
-Yeah, we're doing
the English dubbing.
-I was gonna say, whoever does
the voice sounds just like you.
[ Laughter ]
Wait. So you act --
you act the whole show --
You do it in...
-Swedish and in English, yeah.
-Whoa!
-Yeah.
-You're putting the work in,
man.
Wow! That's fantastic.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Thank you, thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You know how to do it.
These guys are putting
the work in.
You're so,uh --
-I love this crowd.
-Yeah. Well...
-They're amazing.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You guys are...
-The energy.
-You feel the energy, right?
-Yeah, yeah.
-I know, yeah.
You have fans, by the way --
Obviously, you have a giant --
you were in a giant boy band.
-Giant boy band.
-Yeah.
-I would say giant.
-In Sweden, at least, yeah.
-Yeah, in Sweden, yeah.
But, I mean,
you opened for One Direction.
-Yeah.
-Here's a picture of you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Look at that guy.
Look at that cute little guy.
-Look at that.
-Hi, Harry.
[ Laughter ]
-Hi, Harry. What do you remember
about this tour?
-Um, it was a crazy experience.
It was in one of
the biggest arenas in Sweden.
And we were a band for a year
when we opened for
One Direction.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Yeah.
And we were like 15.
-Coming from playing, like,
high school, from a garage
or someone's living room
to an arena...
-Well, almost, yeah, yeah.
-We did these, like, flash mobs
in the streets.
-Yeah, our thing was performing
on the streets
and recording it, like,
lip-syncing to our songs.
And then we uploaded it
on YouTube.
And then, we ended up there.
-Yeah, I guess
that's a big deal.
-That's crazy.
-As you do.
-Is this before the --
because Justin Bieber --
I remember
you opened for Bieber,
and that was the big break.
-Yeah. Well, so, that was
our first gig as a group at all.
So, the first time we ever
went up on stage together,
it was opening for Justin Bieber
three nights in a row.
Hi, Justin!
[ Laughter ]
-Hi, Justin, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
When you first
auditioned together,
did you have instant chemistry
and go,
"Oh, I can work with this guy.
We're gonna be buddies."
-Well, yeah, but the thing was,
Omar was a bit late.
-Ooh!
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, you had missed a bus
or something.
So, he came in, like,
all sweaty and stressed out.
And the thing was,
I remember, I saw his face,
and I recognized him because
he was famous already.
He was a celebrity in Sweden
because of the band.
But I also -- I attended that
Justin Bieber concert in 2013.
-You were there?
-Yeah, I was there.
-You were like 10.
-Yeah, I was like
10 years old or something.
Yeah.
I just went with a buddy
'cause he had a ticket over.
And then, these guys opened.
They were singing a song
about kangaroos.
-Now forever you'll be --
But now together you guys
will be always known as --
What are they calling you now?
Wilmon?
-Yeah, Wilmon.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I got to say, also,
when we booked you on the show,
everyone was going --
fans were going nuts.
And they're like, "Well, you
better bring back season three.
'Cause season one and two --
They better be coming back
for season three."
And I go,
"I have nothing to do with this.
I'm just a fan
of 'Young Royals.'"
I'm just saying
it's a good show
and everyone
should check it out.
It's done well.
It's acted well.
It's written well.
And then one fan
actually tweeted
every single day,
"Good morning, Netflix.
Another beautiful day
to renew 'Young Royals.'"
Every single day.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, I'm happy to say,
it just got picked up
for season three.
So, congratulations.
-Yay!
[ Cheers and applause ]
What can we --
What can we say about season
three without spoiling anything?
-Well, I mean,
it's still very early.
The script
is still being written.
But we know that it's going
to be the final season.
So -- which is kind of --
It's bittersweet.
But we're looking forward
for this chapter to close
and what's gonna happen
with Simon and Wilhelm.
-Yeah, and we're looking forward
to see them smile.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah.
-They -- all right.
-They don't smile a lot.
-They might smile
in season three.
-Hopefully.
-I want to show everyone a clip
here from season two
of "Young Royals."
Take a look at this.
-Edvin Ryding, Omar Rudberg!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Season one and two
of "Young Royals"
are streaming now on Netflix.